portable power stations have been a game
changer in my life especially now when
we're remodeling our kitchen we have to
shut off power being able to still plug
things in and use different tools and
charge batteries is amazing now this is
the Ops Mega 5000 it is an absolute
beast and when Ops reached out and
wanted to partner with us they want to
send us this battery pack I wasn't sure
but then I looked at the specs and I
looked at more importantly the batteries
they're using and the capacity I said
all right send it over I'll test it out
now not only does this output 4 000
Watts consistently it can output a peak
of 7000 Watts which is crazy by itself
but what's even crazier is that this has
over 5 kilowatt hours of battery in
there other Alternatives some that cost
more will have about three thousand
thirty five hundred this has 5 000 they
pack in here now if that's not enough
you can use their smart extra battery
plug it in with their high quality cable
and Bam you have ten thousand and eighty
kilowatt hours of battery capacity now
before I tell you guys all the great
features about this and what impressed
me some cool things I haven't seen
before I just want to show you guys what
you can run with something like this now
of course a lot of people use this for
backup when their power goes out some
places have bad power storms things like
that now if you're in that situation
you're not going to run everything in
your house like you normally would I
would shut off my hot tub in that case
you'll get two to three days of
emergency battery backup with just one
of these and if you double it you can
get four to six days which is really
really good now when you're not doing
that you can use this for all sorts of
different things for example if you're
going out camping or you're doing
something else you need to have power
you can charge an iPhone 14 about 400
times from one of these not with the
extra one you could take an empty
MacBook Air and charge that about 100
times all the way from empty to full
hopefully that tells you guys how much
power is in this thing now here is a
full chart there are estimates for one
of these batteries now keep in mind
running a microwave it says over three
hours but you know around the microwave
for three hours at a time you'll run it
for a minute heat up your food and
you're done same thing with a coffee pot
with the stove some other things like if
you're sleeping you need a CPAP machine
well that you have a long time that it
can run and you're going to be running
that at night with a 10 watt light bulb
you get over 400 hours now my light
bulbs at home are about six Watts almost
half of that so that can give you a
picture of how long things will last
with just one of these so if that's how
much capacity is in here how long does
it take to charge well the first thing I
impress me is charging just from a
standard outlet this was able to charge
it over 2 000 Watts the previous
absolute best I saw was 1800 and then
the next best was 1600 so that is great
by itself but you can also charge it
with solar so with six solar panels this
thing will take about three and a half
hours to charge up now you can also
charge it from a car it's slower 10 amps
but if you're driving your alternator
spinning creating electricity that's
nice to be able to just plug it in and
make sure that it's charged now if you
combine solar and wall power you can
charge this in one and a half hours that
is really crazy so for the amount of
capacity being able to charge this
quickly is awesome so if you're out of
power you can go somewhere plug it in
charge go home and you are set now it
also has an EV charging port on this
thing so if you're on the go you stop by
an EV charger plug it in and charge up
now other than remodeling I have used
portable power packs for so many things
we love going camping and a lot of
camping spots you don't have power so
having the ability to plug one of these
in and run everything you need including
your air conditioning is amazing if it's
105 degrees out one time when we went
camping you're sitting in a hot box in
there where it's just insane or if
you're outside charging all your
electronics that is awesome now with
that we have done projects in my
backyard like I showed you guys where I
have to run a crazy long extension to be
able to do that rolling this thing out
and being able to plug something into it
is awesome and with the right adapter
you can actually charge up an electric
car from this thing which is really cool
and then of course all your standard
Electronics I got my homepod mini
plugged into this laptops tablets
whatever you want so it's very versatile
now on the front here we have five 20
amp outputs regular Jacks not 15 amp 20
which is great and then we have our 30
amp RV plug which is really nice we also
have four USBS three of them are quick
charge and then two USB C PDS up to 60
watts so you can charge up your Macbook
Air without a problem even my 16 inch I
charge without an issue but if you want
the fastest charge you just plug into a
regular Jack and then we have the 12
volt output now on the front you also
have your screen that shows you all your
information and your Internet of Things
button for the smart app now before I
tell you guys about that I have to talk
about the cells that are in here these
use lfp cells the same chemistry
technology that Tesla uses in that lasts
over four times longer than your
standard lithium battery so a lot of
battery packs in the market that seem
like a great price well they're rated
for 800 Cycles or so so you get about a
year and a half if you're using it daily
now with this thing if you completely
drain it and then charge it in a date
which is tough to do after 10 years
you'll still have over 80 percent of the
original capacity so I'm from 5000 watts
to over 4 000 kilowatt
um that is a lot so the life of
expectancy of this is great now with
that the batteries in themselves there's
four fans that cool it down they have
advanced Protection Systems from the
getting too hot to make sure there's no
extra voltage to make sure that it does
last now as you guys can see these
things are beasts they are fairly large
actually quite small for the capacity
but they're still big they have a lot of
batteries in there so it's heavy so they
do have a grab handle that you can
extend so you can easily roll it around
wherever you need to go and then it
doesn't feel like it's a burden at all
it works great now when you do have to
lift it up uh you do have these sturdy
handles built into the top which you can
grab to pick it up and put into your car
or things like that now as far as a
smart portion of this you have a QR code
you can scan so you can easily find the
app download it and then you can push
the Internet of Things button to enable
Wi-Fi and Bluetooth to connect to it so
once you set it up it can connect to
your network and then you don't even
have to be close to it could be anywhere
you can monitor the battery and if you
don't have Wi-Fi you can connect to
Bluetooth and check it out now in the
app you see everything the battery the
amount of power that is coming in the
matter power that is coming out you can
even turn on and off these different
outputs right here because if they're on
they do drain a little bit of power just
from the circuitry that's normal and
there's even timeout so if nothing's
being used something gets fully charged
it will automatically shut off you can
update your firmware there's even smart
control so you can pair it with Alexa or
with Google so there's a lot of cool
things in the app and it is so handy to
have that especially if you're going out
camping I could be in my RV open it up
check to see if things are on and off
press the button bam I am all set now
you also get a warranty card and you
have a manual that is printed it's
pretty simple but at least you have it
you can access it online too but they
don't force you to have to go online to
get it now the other cool thing is that
this can be used as a UPS one big UPS so
you can plug it into the wall plug in
the things that you need that will
connect in here for example the Mac Pro
that I have the display that I have
those use a lot of power so when you
plug it in here and if the power goes
out it will switch to the batteries and
then we'll power up whatever you want to
stay on which is important for a desktop
or for uh like a storage server so that
part is great it's pure sine wave so you
can make use of that instead of just
waiting for an emergency situation or if
you're going camping so with that said
if you want a battery pack that has a
bunch of different capabilities great
battery cells and you don't want to pay
a crazy amount of price for it something
that's a premium level for some brands
that just charge a ton of money for
various reasons Ops has been around they
have a lot of different products and
they just offer great value for the
money I did a lot of research into Ops
and there's been other guys that did
full amperage tests draw test capacity
test and everything met their advertised
specifications so I wanted to make sure
that was set so if you're looking for
something like this I have a link in the
description to their indeed GoGo page
with the launch where they're going to
have you know launch deals and their
main website for you guys to check out
go ahead and click that Circle above to
subscribe check out one of those videos
right over there this has been Max and
I'll see you in the next one
[Music]